when somebody plays Karo Khan against
you it is very rare that you can employ
an aggressive Gambit in the opening
stage
well in my past I have created the
sparsky Gambit against the Karo Gangnam
and if you haven't checked it out you
definitely want to have a look at it
but in today's lecture we are going to
see one of the most deadliest and
attacking chess Gambit against the
karakan starting with Bishop to C4
so at first sight it looks very silly
right as you allow what black wants to
do D5
but now comes the big idea rather than
capturing the Deep Pawn we are going to
play Bishop to B3 and Gump it the E4
Pawn
[Music]
so in this first episode we are only
going to look at the accept variation
and in my next video we are going to
look at the decline part
okay D captures E4
and now comes this very nice move
Queen to H5 and this is known as Shaffer
Gambit as well as hillybilly attack
so as you can see
white has break the opening rules and
taken out the queen but it thoroughly
justify as we are attacking on F7 and
accordingly black has two choices
now I have even seen people have played
the Moon Knight to F6 where after Queen
captures F7 black is just losing the
battle at the opening stage
but
first let's start with the main line
that is G6 attacking the queen
please note we are not interested here
Queen to E5 as after Knight to F6 black
obtained the good game
but in all these lines the home for the
queen you have to remember is
Queen to H4
where our Queen is nicely situated and
if allowed more or less we are planning
to get our Pawn back
okay
black plays Knight to F6 defending on e4
we are going to renew it with Knight to
C3
and now three popular choices from the
black side
amongst them two of them tried to hold
on to the spawn and the last one just
ignore it and play Bishop to G7
let's start with the bad move first
Queen to D4
at first side looks like good way to
hold on to this Pawn but in fact after
this
white quickly get the upper hand with
the following sequence
D3
kindly note that pawn is spin so black
cannot take it
and now if black really want to hold on
to this Pawn then he has to play Bishop
to F5
afterwards I proposed this nice sequence
Knight to F3 attacking the queen
to be six
and now Pawn takes E4 and believe it or
not but just at the ninth move of the
game black is completely losing
yup you can try any Bishop moves all
leads to disaster
for example if Bishop goes to C8 then we
have this nice move Knight to G5
attacking on F7 and after E6
what else this nice big sacrifice Knight
captures E6 Bishop captures E6 and now
very simple choice
Queen captures F6 attacking two
locations
so that if black foolishly play Rook to
G8 then he is going to find out to his
horror that after Bishop to E6 he can't
even touch of a bishop at the end result
he is going to lose his Rook on the G8
Square
so just 13 move and black is finished on
the spot
well you might say hang on I don't need
to play Bishop to see it here I can play
Bishop to G4 more aggressive response
attacking the Knight right
nope more or less same story we can play
Knight to G5 attacking on F7 and after
E6
yup you guessed it E5 and black is
losing one of the Pieces Just within
11th move of the game
so you can see Queen to D4 leads to the
opening disaster for the black
so by far the main line here is Bishop
to F5 defending on the E4 Pawn
well after this I am going to recommend
you play a true Gambit Style
starting with F3
and the point is after e captures F3 and
the Moon Knight captures F3
just like black modem or Gambit we get
open enf file where we are going to
generate
a tremendous attack on the black king
so after Bishop to G7 as you can see I
have highlighted by the arrows very
simple and effective plan of campaign
from the black side is
you play D4 followed up with Bishop to
F6 and Knight to G5 where depending on
the circumstances we can Castle on
either side
and even though black can see this one
is coming the amazing part is there are
hardly any ways to defend these threats
well to illustrate how we can achieve
this in the real game I am going to show
you two games
so in the first game after D4 black
indeed Castle on the king side
and
when white plays the obvious move Bishop
to H6
he continued with Knight to D7 afterward
White Castle on the king's side
so it's very important to line up this
Rook on the file so we can sacrifice at
some of this black pieces
and what really amazed me that if you
look at the Top Choice here from the
black namely Knight to B6
where black is intending to play Knight
to D5
completely fails with our obvious move
Knight to G5
and if you think that well it is not
going to help it as black can simply
respond with the Top Choice Knight B to
defy
guess what
black has fallen for our most decisive
opening trick
and before I move on if you want you can
pause the video and find out a killer
move here from the white
I am showing it right now
look at this
boom
what a move
well we are clearly distracting F5
Bishop and no matter however black plays
from here he is going to lose the game
for example if he continue with Bishop
takes G4 then the planning of the white
is very simple
first you take on D5
obviously black cannot take on D5 with
the Knight as after Bishop to F6 and
queen captures at 7. black king is going
to be checkmated
so yup C captures D5 is the only
response but after this our task is very
easy
Bishop G7 King G7 and now the star move
in the picture
destroying the defender of that seven
with this lovely exchange sack
Rook takes F6 which happen
time and time again in the slide
what to play it is already looking so
bad for the black
and just to illustrate how deadly this
position is
one of my recent game finished very
quickly and this is all part of the
preparation my opponent played King
takes F6 thinking that I am going to
escape with my king
but look at this
Rook to even closing all doors for the
black ink and in fact my opponent played
the immediate blunder with Bishop to H5
which finished the game in just mere two
moves
did you spot it
congratulations if you find the move
Knight to E6
and after King to F5 and queen to G5
the pictures Checkmate occurs on the
boat
so guys this is one of the high profile
trick in this Knight to D5 Edition which
you should definitely remember in your
own game
so it is pretty clear that if black
castles then he is playing right into
the white sand
so some of the wise black player
continue with Knight B to D7 and after
our Bishop to F6
rather than castling and playing into
the White Hand they continue with the
second most popular choice namely Bishop
takes at six
okay no issues we are going to take back
with Queen
and now black would love to play Knight
to G4 but Queen to G7 creates some
problems
so accordingly
the most famous Choice here is Queen to
C7
trying to Castle on the Queen's side
well against this specific variation I
am going to propose you should Castle on
the queen side
so that if black now Castle on the queen
side then we can munch on F7 and get our
material back
so that's not a good choice for the
black and accordingly black has tried
two majority of the options
either E6 or E5
now if your opponent continue with E5
then this is again leads to the opening
disaster as after the simple move Knight
to G5 attacking on F7
Rook to f8 defending
and now D captures E5
more or less gives white a long lasting
advantage
for example Black's idea is he wants to
play Knight to G4 not only attacking the
queen but looking at Juicy F2 Square
whereupon we can defend both of this
thread with
Queen to H4
and after black Castle
here comes the whole point
Knight captures F7 winning the whole
Exchange
if black doesn't move the Rook then we
are happy to chop it off
and Rook to E8 doesn't stop it as after
Knight to D6 chat King to B8 and the
move Knight captures E8
not so surprising just within the 18th
move of the game white obtained The
Exchange
so far I have reached to this position
few times in my game and all of my
opponent continue with E6
which looks more natural
so now you defend all of the white
thread and ready to Castle on the queen
side
but I think it has another big drawback
and that white can exploit starting with
this very nice move H3
so our idea is very simple we want to
play G4 and trapping down this bishop
and for time being this bishop is safe
so my opponents continue with Castle on
the queen side
But Here Comes the big surprise
we can play this engine move Rook to a
fun
whereupon black is completely busted
to illustrate what is white thread
if let's say black plays any casual move
King to B8
then after jifu Bishop to E4 and the
Moon Knight to G5
suddenly black realized that he has
completely lost as white has double
threat number one capture on e4 number
two the obvious one Knight F7 and
winning the exchange
so that is the big time threat here and
accordingly
in my game my opponent continued with E5
so his idea is he wants to play Bishop
to E6
and
save his Bishop
but once again this G4 move gives wide a
winning age after the following sequence
Bishop to E6
Knight takes E5 Bishop takes B3
Pawn takes B3
now white has a threat of Knight to C7
so my opponent took this Knight
but what he missed is after Rook takes
F6
Knight to D7 and Rook chapter zap7
suddenly
not only white is emerging with an extra
Pawn
but
our next move is very obvious Rook caps
is at 7 and winning a yet another Pawn
which is in fact happened in the game
Queen to D6 unpinning the Knight but
doesn't stop Rook captures at seven and
the end result with the two point
Advantage black cannot survive from this
position
the third option I want to consider is
Bishop to G7
so black says okay you can have your
Pawn back but I am going to concentrate
on my peace development
and yes indeed if white wish he can take
it back but I am going to propose this
straightforward approach starting with
F3
so that after Pawn takes and Knight
takes the only difference here is black
has not committed the move Bishop to fi
but it doesn't matter to us as our
planning of campaign will remain
consistent
let me show you one of my recent game
which highlight how good this position
is for the white
my opponent Castle on the king side
I played D4
and after he continued with Bishop to G4
I simply Castle on the king's side
Black's idea is he wants to get rid of
this dangerous night
but in doing so he allows my Rook
swinger
which happens frequently in this line
after Knight bd7 Bishop to F6
and Knight to B6
you can almost guaranteed this is going
to happen in most of the games
whereupon I propose this new moon
Knight to E2
so that if your opponent continue with
Knight to D5
we can safely play Rook to H3
creating a big problem for the black
for example in the game my opponent
doesn't realize the potential of white
in this position and continue with E6
but after just three moves Bishop
captures G7 King captures G7 Queen two
at six Jack King to G8 and now Rook to
F1
white has a very simple plan what he
wants to do is he wants to capture this
Knight and then do the exchange SEC on
F6
which
believe it or not even though black and
sea it's coming
amazingly enough he cannot prevent it
guess what
the engine says there is a mate in sex
so this sort of attack you can expect
from the hillybilly attack when black
accepts our Gambit paw
now before we finish the quick note what
to do against the move E6
and I think this is certainly a bad
choice due to the obvious reason black
made his light skirt Bishop now a
passive peace
so a sample line can goes like this
Knight to C3 trying to get a weapon bag
Knight to F6 defending and now yup the
home for our Queen
H4
so that now we are going to get our Pawn
back
the only way black can try to hold on to
this extra Pawn is by playing Queen to
D4
but as we have seen in the earlier part
this is not the right choice as after
simple move Knight to F3 attacking the
queen
to B4
now we play A3 completely dislodging
this queen from the pawn and after Queen
to B6 and the Moon Knight captures E4
yup we get our Pawn back and the end
result is we have once again The Simple
Plan
that is play the move default take out
this bishop and then depending on of a
choice we can Castle on either side
where the burning question from the
black remained the same
what to do with this passive Bishop as
he already committed the move E6
so this is how you should respond if
your opponent continue with E6
thank you
that's it guys I hope with this lecture
now we are confident enough that when
your opponent take the spawn
then after Queen to H5 no matter however
black plays
white get very good attacking scheme on
the black king
and even though in some lines we have to
sacrifice upon the Furious attack and
easy to play positions
compensate more than enough to give
white an entertaining line against the
Carroll Khan
stay tuned as in my next episode we are
going to look at the decline variation
and once again I am going to show you
some of the nasty surprises from the
white side
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
buy and take care